【はじめの咳払い】
そうだ！
Twitterでも見てみるか！
「勉強なう」
えらいぞ
頑張れ！
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
はい というわけで今年ももう
終わりでございますね
ま 全体的な振り返りは
もっと年末にするとして
えー 僕の
スマートフォン
の動画、振り返っていきましょう
僕 いつでしたっけ？
なんか前 昔も似たような企画
やったんすよね
あの 僕ね、毎年更新していこうかな
と思いまして
出したいけど出したら絶対炎上するし
なんかみんなになんか言われそうな…
だ、動画みたいのを我慢して
スマホで撮って自分で
友達とかと楽しんでるんですよ
で なんかもう今年 2017年も
結構いろんな変な動画溜まったんで
今回それを皆で見ていこうかなと思います
なかなか 人には見せられないような
やつもあるんですけども
まぁ 年末だからいっか！
はいというわけでまあ
まあ順番に見ていきましょう
これは結構最近なんですけど
なんか UUUMに行ったら
トミックさんがなんかカニ持って暴れてて
何だこいつ？って思って
カニ なんかお腹空いてるかなと思って
果汁グミの、あのオレンジ味を
（動画内はじめ：くっさ！くっさ！）
プイって あの、ハサミに
（動画は：くっさ！）
つけてあげたんですけど
そしたらなんかトミックさんが
鼻にハサミを入れてみよう
みたいなことを言い出して
無理矢理 カニのハサミを
鼻の穴に入れられてる動画です
（動画は：臭い臭い臭い！）
（動画は：鼻の穴が臭い！）
【動画内はじめの咳】
（動画は：痛、痛い！待って！）
（動画は：待って待って待って！）
ハッハハ！
いや あの これ、マジで痛かったです
トミックさん 二度とこんなこと
しないでください
カニさん ほら、下に
果汁グミ握ったまま
横移動していくっていう
なにやってんだか
これ あの お寿司屋さんに
行ったときの動画ですね
これは あの俺 なんもやって無いんですけど
なんもやって無いんですけど
気付いたら なんか
厚焼き玉子が こう
渋滞になってて
あの 突っかかってるなと思って
なんか どうなるんだろ？
ほら 次のもどんどん来ちゃって
うわー 大変だなと思って
回した動画です
あのー この後 裏のなんか店員さんが
直したんで大丈夫でした
はい えー これはですね
今年 ちょっと忙しかったときがあって
夏ですね、東京で
そしたら なんかたなっちが寝てて
撮ってる動画です
僕と一緒で 口開けて寝る
タイプみたいですね
【動画内：ヒゲソリの音】
起きちゃいました
これ確か UUUMにいるときに なんか
あの 脅かそうとして
やってたやつです 確か
入ってきたところを脅かせるっていう
（動画は：うわぁぁーーっ！）
（動画内ターゲット：うわぁっ！！）
ハッハハww
なんとも言えねえ
あと これはあれですね
タクシーで移動中のときに
寝てるたなっちですね
やっぱ夏は忙しかったんでね
こういう 寝ることがよくありました
【動画内：たなっちの寝言】
（動画は：なに言ってるか分かんない）
変なの
これ 無理矢理
寝てるンダホを起こそうとする俺です
（動画は：ンダホ？）
（動画は：ンダホ はじめ帰るね）
（動画内シルク：
はじめくん帰っちゃうって）
（動は：ンダホ？）
（動画シ：バイバイは？）
（動画シ：
はじめくん帰っちゃうって！）
（動画は：はははっwww 早い）
（動画シ：
はじめくん帰っちゃうって）
（動画は：バイバイ）
（動画シ：いってらっしゃいww）
（動画は：いってきます）
起きろー！
なんだこれ？なんだっけこれ？
あっそうだ！あの 太郎あげあげくん
ゲロ吐いてるやつを あの
横から実況してあげてました
本当にこれ ゲロ吐いてるんで
ちょっと気持ち悪かったんですけど
なんか ね、せっかくなんで
記念に撮ろうかなと思って
後ろからずっと撮ってました
（動画内太郎：何のシーン？）
（動画は：www）
（動画太：体あげていいっすか？）
（動画は：いいよ）
（動画太：待って おかしい）
ゲロも汚いし顔も汚いわ！
（動画内マスオ：やめてよー！）
ふっww
（動画マ：やめてよー！）
なんか これ マスオさんが
スプラトゥーンの実況で
やめてよ～！ って言ってるのが
すごいなんか 印象深かったんで
動画撮ってました
【動画内はじめの嗚咽】
これ 食べすぎてゲロ吐きそうに
なったときですね
これなんだっけ ここ2人が後輩2人で
なんか 横断歩道でふざけなさいって
言ったんですけど いまいち
ふざけきれなかった動画ですね
おー おー
なんだこれ？ 俺なに撮ってんだ？
滝の上からの絵が撮りたくて
やってたんだ
（動画内よっち：ボコッ！）
（動画よ：ざき！）
（動画よ：イェェェェェェェェ！！！）
はっwww
（動画よ：ェェェェェェェェイ！！！）
懐かしい
（動画よ：ジャスティス！）
なんか 暇すぎてよっちに
やらせました 外で
これ最近ですね なんか 家の外で
まだ叫ぶ
まだなんか 「はじめー！」
「はじめー！」って叫ぶ
中学生の子がいたんで
もう 結構怒って
メチャンコ注意しました
うん
なんか 懲りずにまだやるのかな？
すごいね
これは あれですね
禁断ボーイズの田中が
俺ん家に遊びに来たときに
あの ヒカキンさんの顔をずっと
こうやって殴ってました
ほんとに まじやめろよ！ ほんと
また遊ぼうね！
そらちぃじゃん
なにしてんだ
寝てるのか！
寝てるねー
まだ髪の毛があるときだ
膝 汚っ！
水掛けようとしたけど
やめたな
優しいな俺！
これ たぶん Twitterで出したと
思うんですけど なんか
あの 仮面ライダーエグゼイドかな？
エグゼイドの なんか
ゲームが凄い面白くて
変身できるんすよ
変身しました！
ほら 変身しても中腰なんですよ
すごいでも 僕 この動きがやっぱ
僕 早いみたいで
結構ハイスコアだったみたいですね
これは
良かったです
電気ビリビリのやつだ
電気ビリビリを なんか
はははっwww
寝てるのに電気ビリビリの握らせたら
すごい痛がってて楽しかったです
これも電気ビリビリですね
何でスロー何だよ！ww
俺なんで これスローにしたんだろう？
おー おー おー
これは当たると電気ビリビリ
ってなるやつなんです
はーーww
痛そーww
俺だめだな なんか人の痛がるの
ばっかり見て楽しんでるんだなー
これはてつやと車で移動してたら
なんか原付の人が楽しそうに
手振りながら運転してて危ねえな
って思ったところですね
あと 車がすごい汚かったです
これは編集してるトミックさんですね
やっぱりトミックさんは あの
正面から見るより横で見たほうが
迫力があるんでちょっと横面も
おさえておこうかなと思って
横の絵をおさえてみました
あ 気付いた！
口閉じろや！
あくび
これ あの てつやの服が
穴空いてたんで
塩のショットガン
すごい撃ちやすかったんで
めっちゃ撃ってあげてる動画です
（動画内てつや：あぁーっ！）
すごい痛いんですよ
ラブライブのでかいのが
車走ってたんで感動して
撮っただけっていう
（動画は：わぁっ！）
（動画内誰か：きゃん！）
ふっww
なんか 誰かから 確か
カードを貰ったんですけど
それが なにか分かんなくて
開けるやつだった気がします
えー 何だっけ？これ？
俺全然覚えてねえな
（動画は：いきますよー）
（動画は：あ、まだある！）
（動画は：これ横スリだ）
（動画は：いきます！）
（動画は：はい！）
（動画内：www）
そう 俺の顔が貼ってありましたww
はい！というわけで
いかがだったでしょうか
なんかやっぱね
こう 動画だと なんかちゃんと
しなきゃな とか思っちゃったりするんで
なんか こういうスマホの動画って なかなか
まあ レアかなと思って
今年もやってみました
来年もまたスマホで
変な動画いろいろ撮って
また年末に紹介しようと思います！
次の動画でお会いしましょう
じゃあな！！
【ED (軽やかな音楽ver.)】